[Applause]
yes that's making local and Prince Harry
getting a front-row seat to a marriage
proposal the Dutchess of Sussex unable
to contain her emotions as she watched
the sweet moment happen directly in
front of her at Thursday's endeavor
Awards held at Mansion House in London
the event marked Harry and Megan's first
joint appearance since relocating to
Canada and while the Sussex is were all
smiles as they stepped out in the rain
Thursday night they actually look as if
a burden has been lifted from their
shoulders their fans seem to have mixed
emotion but then again so did this this
is the first time we're seeing Megan
back in the UK since she left for Canada
in early January I would imagine there's
a little trepidation she would be a
little anxious coming back and having to
face members of the public charities and
of course the royal family for the very
first time
but if Megan was nervous she didn't show
it the 38 year old Duchess looked
incredible in a fitted blue knee-length
Victoria Beckham dress with her long
hair pulled back in a sleek ponytail and
navy heels
Harry perfectly complemented her look in
a dapper navy suit while he kept them
dry holding an umbrella over their heads
before attending the annual awards
ceremony which celebrates the
achievements of wounded injured and sick
servicemen and women who've participated
in remarkable athletic challenges over
the last year Megan and Harry first
attended the event in 2018 when they
were still engaged and again in 2019
when Megan was pregnant with their now
10 month old son Archie this year's
endeavour awards marks the first time
we've seen Megan and Harry attend a
public event together since announcing
their decision to step down as senior
members of the royal family in January I
think both Harry and Megan are going to
really want to end on a high this is
their final chapter as senior members of
the royal family the Sussex a--'s
official transition happens on March
31st we'll see them attend a variety of
events before then including Monday's
Commonwealth Day service where they'll
reunite with Prince William and Kate
Middleton 2019 was a very difficult year
there were a lot of rumors of feuds and
risks the body language experts are
going to be out in force they're going
to be interpreting every blink every
yawn every eye roll every facial
appearance every gesture
Megan inhere he are expected to fly back
to Canada after the service on Monday
evening thought she is at home so
they're going to want to return to him
as quickly as possible after that we
hope we'll see them again in the coming
months Harry is planning to be in London
in April for the London Marathon we'll
also see them in May in The Hague for
the Invictus games
[Music]